hello everyone my name is tim brander
with ibm cloud today i'd like to show
you how to take advantage of obtainium
complies integration into ibm cloud
security compliance center or sec for
short
what we're going to do is solve the
problem of providing more complete
security and compliance posture in one
view using multiple tools but first a
little about scc
it provides you a unified single pane of
glass experience for all of your secured
and compliance postures it provides you
continuous compliance monitoring against
pre-defined profiles based on security
best practices and industry compliance
standards
in addition it provides preventative
enforcement of secure configuration of
your ibm cloud services to proactively
prevent misconfigurations of cloud
resources
and then to top it all off we provide
hybrid multi-cloud support so you can
scan multiple clouds as well as on-prem
resources for security best practices
now what is tadium
titanium platform unifies security and
it operation teams with a single view of
critical endpoint data in real time
all through a single platform and agent
trust by half of the fortune 100 and
largest government networks titanium
provides a comprehensive and high
fidelity source of truth so that
organizations see every endpoint whether
that be hybrid cloud containerized
on-prem remote and can make informed
decisions in real time
ibm cloud and tanium working together
was a natural partnership to allow for
the best of both worlds to bring the
power of our joint solutions together
with this integration customers can
deepen their capabilities for reducing
the possibility of a breach or a
security event
now ibm cloud is becoming the most
secure cloud provider making security
and compliance easier and more secure by
default
tadium does a great job of discovering
unknown assets in a large scale
enterprise like finding an unmanaged
laptop with malware or
improving your patch success rate within
minutes
so how does integration actually work
here's a diagram of what you're about to
see in this video now i'm going to be
playing the role of the compliance
engineer that knows ibm cloud titanium
and the problem we're trying to solve is
seeing compliance results from ibm cloud
and tanium in one dashboard
okay so the first thing that i'm going
to go do is uh go to cloud.ibm.com just
log into my ibm cloud account
now there's several ways that you can
access ibm cloud security and compliance
center the first way is going to be
through our hamburger menu and what
you're going to do is just scroll down
to security and compliance it's right
next to satellite and vmware
the second way is through a widget
that's on a pre-built dashboard for a
security focal and the other way is to
go up to the manage and security
compliance menu item
okay so now i'm just going to go click
on security compliance and that brings
me into the security and compliance
center
now the first thing i'm going to go do
is click on integrations because we want
to set up titanium so i'm going to go
down to the titanium tile click on
connect
and i'm going to fill out the connection
name this could be any name
the registration url is just the url
that you're going to be going to for
your tanium instance
then i'm going to click on next
there's two
result formats oscal or native for this
instance
titanium is in native so i'm going to
click on native and click on connect
now the result is a service id and api
key that allows me to have a secure
connection between tanium and security
compliance center
i'm going to download that and also copy
it to clipboard but i'm going to be
saving that to put into titanium later
okay
so now that i've got that done i'm going
to go and click on configure
and go to scopes because i need to put a
place where i want all the information
to go this is in our concept of scopes
scopes is basically just the resources
of where i want things to go
i'm first going to create a scope i'm
going to give it a name
and click on next
go to the environment scroll down to
on-prem
and then in the next menu item i'm going
to go ahead and click on
the connect third-party resources and
then a new menu pops up that shows
tanium there's a couple connections that
i have but i'm going to just connect to
the one that i just built
and then click on next
now in this next one we usually have a
collector that is installed but in this
instance tanium is the collector so we
don't have to do this part so all i have
to do now is just click on next
and now i just review all the details
that i just put in and click on create
what that does is create the scope and
it gives me a url that i want to point
tanium at and to use that api key and
service id in order to securely
communicate from tanium into ibm cloud
security and compliance center
i'm going to copy the url
and bring that over in titanium
along with my api key and then finished
the integration part in tanium
okay that's it
in this video you were able to see
tanium complies integration into ibm
cloud security and compliance center
thanks for watching if you have any
questions please add a comment below if
you want to see more videos like this in
the future please like and subscribe and
don't forget if you want to learn more
about ibm cloud security compliance
center please check out the links below
you